last night when a ball got fumbled into
the end zone and the ball goes to
Carolina just because it's supposedly
you couldn't even tell for sure when
your naked eye that the ball sailed to
the left of the pylon going through the
end zone and out that belonged to
Carolina and had it just trickled out
right before the pylon would have belong
to new - to New Orleans but this rule
this crazy-ass touchback rule I can't
stand it and I figured let's get Dean
Blandino on former a head of NFL refs
and Fox rules analyst back here on the
show how are you Dean I'm good how are
you well I'm pissed II you know be
honest with you you know you know I'm
just pissed I can't stand this rule why
does this rule existing why does it
exist so you know I'm gonna I'm gonna
give you a little background on the rest
what I just rule just goes back to I
mean I've researched it I mean we're
talking 1926 this this rule goes back
and maybe even further but my my records
in my deep dark library that I have in
my basement only go back that far
okay and again it goes to if you put the
ball out of bounds in the end zone it's
treated differently than in the field of
play the end zone is different okay so
we we all accept that the end zone is
different if you if you get the ball in
the end zone in your opponent's end zone
it's a touchdown right if you put the
ball in your own end zone it's a safety
and and it's different in the field of
play so it's consistent with every time
you put the ball in your opponent's
endzone it's a touchback and with the
end zone there's great risk and there's
great will reward and and the key is if
you fumble and you recover it in your
opponent's end zone you you're gonna get
a touchdown and the key there is you
didn't recover you did two bad things
you fumbled you didn't recover it so why
are we going to give you a do-over
and that's and I think that's what
basically what it comes down to it's
it's simple it's consistent with with
loose balls that go into your opponent's
end zone and the end zone as we all know
is just different so here's my response
to that Dean number one just because
Teddy Roosevelt wanted it doesn't mean
we should still want here in 2019 okay
that's number one okay number two number
two end zone might be a little different
here but while we're awarding the
defense which is given up ninety nine
and a half yards the ability to get the
ball back just because somebody was
foolish enough to lead to hold it out
for the pylon or if somebody just
accidentally let it go I think and then
Oh gets number three what do you think I
think you said it you said foolish
enough to reach the ball out and protect
the football I know and that's not the
argument for the rule look you're trying
to score I I get that I get that but
here's the thing if they if they think
about it the other way think about it
the 5-yard line the offense is at their
own five-yard line and they fumble and
that ball goes out of bounds at the half
inch line okay they're gonna get the
ball at the half inch line if it hits
the pylon it's going to be a safety is
that unfair because it's the same
concept it is the same concept I guess
it's the same concept but it's different
in the fact that the defense is getting
rewarded for a player that's trying to
make a big offensive play after they've
given up more likely than not a large
enough amount of time for their for
their backs to be against the wall and I
understand that this is kind of apples
and apples but I'm talking about an
offensive team that's going in to score
mm-hmm right and so suddenly they're
making a aggressive play to score and
because of a two-inch difference they're
losing the football I mean you're saying
and your your other argument is that
because the defense has allowed the
offense to get all the way down the
field and now we're rewarding them yes
and but what if what if the the offense
the other team threw an interception and
the defense returned it to the five and
now New Orleans is starting first and
goal at the five and that play happens
well the defense didn't do anything
right it's still the same rule and I
think that's that's that's the whole
thing again it's the it's the end zone
and I get it look it's a big penalty
it's you lose the football but the thing
is if you fumble if you fumble the ball
into your opponent's end zone there's
only two things it's either a touch back
or or it's a touchdown right
there's no do-overs and it's same-same
the other way right it's either a safety
or or it could be a touchdown well did
you think let's just talk about last
night alone do you think that ball
definitely went through the end zone you
know I don't know and I can tell that's
the other part of it is that is that the
ball looked like it may have crossed
over the pylon and that that is
reviewable they looked at it they
couldn't tell but again think about that
play last night and I'm gonna I'll pose
you the question because there's another
there's another part of this and we
can't lose sight of the fact that the
rule is consistent and simple and we
don't want to complicate these rules but
it was it was third and four from the
five-yard line okay so the line again is
the one if if your your I believe urine
you're in favor of a reverse touchback
concept yes right we're where the
offense gets the ball 220 okay let's say
that rule is in place yes it's third and
four from the five right the ball is
fumbled somewhere near the one-yard line
pretty close yes there's also an
offensive hold called on the play walk
me through the next down and distance
for New Orleans in that situation so if
there's a hold on the play that happened
last night and I have I love this by the
way Dean Glen do you know I love this
you know I live for this sort of thing
I'm glad someone way smarter than me is
making this okay so here's what walks
through is that Oakland accepts my
suggestion of a touchback
because it is now it is now third and
goal from the 20 you don't lose you
don't change it down it's not first you
don't get a fresh set of downs because
you fumble through the end zone its
third and goal from the 20 or play if
the play happened then you decline the
penalty because you're taking the result
of the play which is a fumble in the end
zone and a reverse touch back third and
goal from the 20 why would it be third
and goal why wouldn't it be for them
because it was third and goal that's why
so we're gonna replay the down yes 20
correct so so who New Orleans did three
bad things they fumbled they didn't
recover they held and they're gonna get
they're gonna get to replay the down
from the 20 so now that we're
workshopping it how about lost down it's
like it's like it's like
and millions around watching us trying
to figure this out on the field by the
way so we're trying to work through this
but well Dean Dean I know you're trying
to work through this but we're trying to
we're trying to make sure that something
completely punitive isn't isn't so
punitive and it's just flash of an eye I
mean at least when Derek Carr reached
for the pylon a couple of years ago ball
flew out of his hand it hit the pylon
you could tell I mean last night was
totally arbitrary and these guys I mean
so I agree with you there and that's and
that's ultimately and I still go back to
great risk great reward and I think and
again and I and we can we can try to
workshop this but sometimes I really
don't think we can sacrifice simplicity
for for absolute fairness because
sometimes the rules aren't going to be
perfectly equitable and and I get it and
this is a big play it doesn't happen
very often but I still go back to the
endzone is different and that play last
night had that had we had a reverse
touch back type of rule it would have
been pretty complicated to try to work
through all of it whereas the way the
rule is now it's a touch back Caroline
is getting the ball to 20 decline the
penalty let's go so when you're in your
arrow in the front office of the
National Football League was there any
appetite or do you know of any growing
appetite to change it to the way that I
see it you know there there it has
always been part of the discussion and
and I don't I've never been part of a
competition committee meeting where it
weird ever got to the point where we put
pen to paper and we started to actually
write a proposal and then when when you
when you go down that path that's when
that's when it starts to get serious
when you start to write a proposal and
then you're putting that in front of the
owners for a potential vote it never
never got that far and I'm not sitting
here and saying that it maybe maybe it
could I mean the NFL sometimes is does
react and if this happens in a
championship game or Super Bowl and
people feel that that's not an equitable
result maybe maybe there there might be
more appetite I know right now there is
not a lot of appetite to change this is
that because John Merrow sat in the room
and
about when his dad created the rule in
19 2016 it's possible possible might
have been you know Pereira who was there
at the time now he might have been the
one that you know good deal with it but
great job right there Dino so before I
let you go I ask this of Mike last week
and Onalaska of you now Dean Blandino
former head of NFL refs and Fox rules
analyst there is so much going on in the
NFL that we that that gets overshadowed
by the Twitter conversation or just in
general about the officiating and calls
that look so obvious that aren't called
and there was a delay of game penalty
that could have been called in Denver
just as if for example the the
Pittsburgh fans are still howling over
the lack of a false start call that led
to a touchdown that sparked Philip
Rivers comeback what what can be done to
fix this Dean yeah I think you know what
Mike suggested it and I think it's I
think it's something that we had
discussed you know in the past you know
it the way the technology is officials
are held to such a high standard and
it's impossible as a human being to see
things in real time and be perfect right
and so I think it there is there is an
appetite and I think it's time to have
that discussion to add a you know a
video official or some concept of that
that you can look at the video and you
can communicate seamlessly with the crew
on the field and fix some of these
obvious mistakes and I think you have to
do it you have to be it has to be
limited and it has to be big plays or
potentially big plays because you don't
want to be riaf Ishi ating the play via
replay or video after every down I think
you have to be again has to be limited I
think we have to use technology to help
the officials on the field because the
game is just too fast to be perfect so
you're talking pre-snap penalties what
else would you throw into that penalty I
wouldn't want a video official looking
for every twitch by the left guard on it
on a three yard run I think you have to
you know it would have to be the big
face mess that's missed it would have to
be something you know a false start
that's missed on a touchdown things like
that that that can impact games and
change outcomes I think those those are
the plays that that I would I would
start with
but you'd have to again you'd have to
come up with a list of plays that you
could look at and again keep it limited
Dean you the man thanks for joining when
you come back to Los Angeles I know
you're out east let's get you back in
studio sir you got that steamed lion tea
no the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience